[Music]  lose weight  declutter my life  I don't know just try to do better than  this year  [Music]  New Year's resolutions I would say  travel more  what would you say uh care about people  born  yeah I'm gonna try to lose some weight  it's an NBC I gave up smoking  ah  pickup  good hobby I guess I don't know one yet  definitely move out of my parents place  remember the next day it's always just  the same spend time with friends and  family continue to walk as much as  possible  to make some money  be a better person do more give back and  enjoy life more keep having fun  stay healthy live a life to its fullest  no matter who's President I work  take care of kids that's about it be a  good daddy yep  uh make money wake up every day and  think that God's still here with us  everyone be safe enjoy life and have fun  stay healthy I'm more of a small steps  kind of a person instead of a big  resolution during New Year's